what about this though because I know a
guy who did a movie it got 0% out wrong
tomatoes that's almost awesome that's
almost impossible to do that's legendary
that's legendary who is it I can't tell
you come on
no off the arrow percent zero movie
that's ever gone I thought that was not
he wrote directed all that stuff I think
he did write it yeah yeah cuz if I in my
head and just give him one very talented
guy
yeah very talented he's like one of the
bad he just made a bad movie I
understand that but I think that was his
first real lead in a real studio thing
oh it was like oh my god yeah and then
that happened they had real people in it
and I mean affected him a lot huh I
don't know I guess I seemed like it did
but I'm just saying that if it happened
to me that would just probably disappear
for a year yeah and just to rework what
I'm gonna do with my life
Wow right well you wouldn't be like that
no man I made I made a shitty sitcom
called mixology that people like [ __ ]
dumped on constantly red for your part
did you really yeah read so many scripts
on that because every acting class uses
that yeah here's the irony of bad
sitcoms that show wasn't that bad it was
just another shitty sitcom but the irony
is like people hate them and they dump
all over them but for some reason people
still will talk about them or like it's
in the zeitgeist of Hollywood which is
so weird yeah which means it's like it's
obviously more affect affected it more
than one that you know there's like
one's from two or three years ago that
we're on for like six episodes and
you'll never hear of them ever again
even remember them yeah there's almost
like a bad ones or more there were there
we we have an addiction to bad movies
the room troll - I did the room I did
the the mock the mockumentary of the
room he did oh you did with James Franco
it's gonna come out this year no artists
well who plays with so dude Franco does
can I can I tell you the best
he was so good it was shocking he put in
headphones he put in headphones every
day for hours and listen to Tommy talk
over and oh my god dude when he got to
set it was like it was like magic he was
exactly like Tommy was oh it was like
watching him
dude you're gonna lose your money it's
it's a an ari Graynor who's on I'm dying
up here plays Lisa oh dude when they do
the pimple back scene yeah you know how
yeah it was so [ __ ] funny we did it a
hundred times because people were like
couldn't hold it in all real Brogan did
it with him and Seth played like a the
fake the fake the fake ad or whatever
yeah and it was so hard to get there
takes like that because we all know
what's coming
yeah just a movie script where you read
a script and you're like all right we're
gonna happen dude right we know what's
happening and you just the reason why
honey is because it actually is real
real is that's why it's so I would not
be able to be there I thought it was so
hard it was so I mean but he would break
like even Franco who was the best at not
breaking there was a few times when it
was like there's no way I hi doggie
would there was no way you don't break
yeah so cuz everyone on set is like
wanting to laugh at that you know what
she talks about that though it's gonna
give I mean I love that movie you're
gonna give him more attention but it's
gonna give Chris that me Tommy was Sal a
lot of attention well so here's what's a
trip so Tommy came to set this is my
favorite thing Tommy came to say he has
guaranteed in his contract to do one
scene with Franco that was like that was
the deal wait that's how that's where he
is up here that he's like it has to be
one-on-one with me and James so of
course you know Seth and and and James
like they signed off on it they're like
fine we'll give this guy what he wants
yeah but you know of course in the world
of Hollywood you're like it doesn't mean
we have to [ __ ] leave it in the movie
but but he was so he this is how in his
own head he is and so like beautifully
in his own space at the wrap party
he came with like five models like I
swear to god he walked downstairs and
he's well these girls he has glasses on
and he's waving like he's blessing us
with his presence and of course dude it
works like it's almost this mindful cuz
everyone rushed up to him it was like
Jonathan oh I got people wanted to like
take pictures because you're enamored
with how insane he is yeah he was he was
so funny to watch Channel yeah they do
to work the room is hilarious I mean
you'd watch him go up to people in like
these terrible conversations and then he
would like leave them like you're
welcome it was amazing but that the
movie will come out I think they just
premiered it at no I know they did it at
South by and the reception was amazing
Franco I think did so much work into it
that's [ __ ] so much about it cuz he
was like he was in love with the room
like so deeply that he wanted to do it
justice so he did seem he shot scene by
scene like parallel scene by scene yeah
and then the rest of it is us filling in
the background world yeah so of course I
play well you guys you guys know the you
guys know the story well if I'm not
given anything away but yeah I I play
the idiot that gets his gets his dick
suck oh my god it was you watch like it
over and over I get to get I mean I
already had seen the room a bunch but I
did watch it a bunch but also on set
they had a bunch of like iPads and stuff
to rewatch those scenes that we had to
reenact oh that's amazing
next one you guys should do is a remake
of the Neal Breen ones that we've been
yes I have to I don't think it says I
don't think that's as crazy as the room
that the room is the top yeah
troll 2 is pretty good though it's
pretty high but dance scene and troll to
patrol to is Scottish is it's um well
troll 2 was almost so bad it's not fun
sometimes
ya know where the room is so bad that
it's funny yeah sometimes some things
are so off bad that you're like I don't
know sometimes it's not it misses the
mark yeah yeah yeah the room scenes that
are so memorably terrible it's because
they cared and it didn't work
yeah so it's almost like if you if they
don't really care and just kind of
making it happen it's it's not that
beautiful but like he thought it was a
good idea to green-screen all of those
rooftop scenes do you know what the
beauty is well he shot on a roof
sometimes he shot on a roof with a green
screen
[Laughter]
oh yeah he wanted to sub in another
cityscape in the background cuz he
didn't want the what medic gone - super
gonzo so far got the details that that
that Franco would divulge were just
amazed the stuff that he learned in
talking to Tommy about like the way he
went about stuff or the way he'd show
like whatever you think the reason was
behind it completely wrong you're way
off like he did everything in a way that
has there's zero sense 0 0 beyond
illusion right because delusion there
are moments where you know there's still
moments of him feeling humiliated or
feeling like wow I you know I let people
down I don't think he has that chip at
all so it's it's a different kind it's
beyond delusion it's like what's the
what's a sociopath is that the word it's
sociopathic right where you're like
above society you think you can
influence yeah the world isn't that
sociopath yeah but I almost wonder if
he's even if he's even capable of
feeling bad like or feeling ya know yeah
Co pathy it's more like no remorse right
with him I don't think he's even able to
stir up any emotions regard cos he's
just out of this world like if someone
died in he would just be oh but it's not
a real oh wow boss knows you're supposed
to say the case that he made a movie
yeah
yeah that James Franco remade about his
you know so he did something right that
did feed his ego the fact that Franco
wanted to read redo it was almost like
imagine him getting the phone call
someone being like James Franco wants to
do movies of course he does if you
haven't seen the room you have to see it
a mother must watch it's a must watch
samurai cop is also a good one I like
samurai to watch samurai with hair right
and he had to wear the way my papa's one
of the best please watch it
okay it's so foul old is it it's 1991 no
it's not okay okay it's not that all
they shot the movie and then months
afterward they had to reshoot the movie
but he had her
cut his hair he's worried is really
weird wig yeah but not only that is that
the director goes hey buddy I'm gonna do
some ADR he shows up his hair short the
guy yells at him why you kill your hair
right he's I think we just do an idiot
know we're shooting half the movie today
he takes him to Hollywood Boulevard at
one of those wig shops and buys her wig
that one and he put it on him and they
shot half the [ __ ] movie with that
hair there's one point where he's in a
fight scene it just comes off you only
did one tank there's a samurai cop too I
know he not a remake though here's what
else yeah there's no here's what
happened so the guy they thought he had
died the main actor yes the inner
because there was a carpenter on the set
with the same exact man and he had died
I swear to God what's the guy's name
do you remark what submit little is Joe
Marshall no or Matthew or Carretas yeah
that's Helena Matthew correct right
people thought he had died and so when
this became a cult sensation people are
like they were in production to make
samurai cop 2 cuz he thought he had died
he changed his name he lived in Colorado
wait wait wait he was he on the run from
something he was no he just decided to
leave LA quit as he was Sylvester
Stallone's bodyguard and then I was like
you know this was a hit and then it
didn't happen so he just left and he
moved to Colorado had kids
that's so crush so his daughter goes dad
I mean online I mean samurai cop is
getting a little heat like I don't know
they all think your dad is your dad and
it took him two years and one day he
just grabbed the camera goes all right
hey I'm REI didn't die you know so
that's that not a try and then he sent
it to his daughter's daughter posted it
and then it became this revival it went
viral right
viral and then all of a sudden he's the
lead in samara cop - what is this come
out came out came out yeah by 2015 ok
here's the thing with those kind of
movies you can't duplicate it no no see
like just the same thing what Franco
does is it's like um it's a tip of the
hat of two that like it's like paying
homage atop tatami is really what it is
yeah he just wanted to show what that
world probably was like behind the
scenes yeah when you hear the interviews
are hilarious like a bunch of the scenes
I shoot with Nathan from oh my god
what's wrong with me
what oh my god you wish from his own
Comedy Central show yeah Nathan for you
why can't I think it was last name I'm
like trying to hide the weirdest blank
huh yeah Nathan fielder fielder and fine
yeah I'm here that was way too much time
never did that guy but he hates you now
forever
yeah but he but we would just sit there
and try to think of how to react because
he would do a ton of improv yeah and
Franco was really good at that yeah why
don't you say he would I come out we'd
be small gonna you know cigarette on the
curb yeah and he Nathan would be like I
don't really know what he wants us to do
he keep saying like more emotion more
emotion but I don't know and he would
come out and he'd go you guys done with
buddy [ __ ] around fast do they keep all
that but take that all of it all of it
alright so they show the stuff behind
the scenes that's what it really is it's
amazing that you can do yes that would
gonna work so so the only the the
scene-by-scene stuff that he duplicated
yeah it's there's only so many of them
right you're yeah but the majority of
thing is like what this world was behind
and they show how many people got fired
how many people quit dude over the
course of this film it was something
insane like 30 crew members quit because
they were like he doesn't even pay
[Laughter]